belgio andremo a picchiarsi con vitare
delle scatole regalo misteriose e in
ogni scatola ci sono degli ingredienti
slime buoni o cattivi e delle sorprese
evitare una volta a testa dovremo
distruggere una questa scatola e
prendere gli ingredienti o le sorprese e
alla fine del video vincerà chi ha gli
ingredienti migliori farlo slime e chi a
ping sorprese tutti ma volete sapere
quali saranno le sorprese tela sarà un
bel ti piace questo video altrimenti
arriverà in quanto neanche alla camera e
martino lo vedete l'ora di sbloccarsi e
i calcoli nelle carte regalo anche i
boccioli tutto di video
la sua pallina come potete vedere molto
messa male che guardi io potrei astros
ti regali le sorprese saranno i nuovi
slime unique and magic boston dell'asl
hobby che potete trovare in edicola è
praticamente ogni volta che li troveremo
nelle scatole dovremmo unirli tutti
assieme
quindi che avrà lo slime e juniper mesi
poi sono più grande di tutti
vincerà ma andiamo a vedere come sono
sono gli oblò billioni con magic boston
e ce ne sono quattro diversi sogni di
unicorno basi di un corno polvere di
unicorno e coccole di unicorno sono in
quattro colori diversi potete
collezionare le quattro opzioni da
collezionare il raccomando chiedete
sempre il magazine
qua ci sono degli unicorni da colorare e
li trovate in edicola a 3 euro e 50
l'uno ma ora siete pronte la cia le
frodi al primo round vediamo chi inizia
prima io ho vitale pronto fra carta fu
iniziata sotto casa poi del tatto carta
forbice fra soci allora mettiamo il
nostro quanto ne potrai mettere ti devo
mettere questo vediamo alle scatola
potrei distruggere secondo voi un pò in
favore di costa verde anche perché c'è 2
volte 2 verdi tata non so se prendere la
rosa o la gialla
[Musica]
mi sa che iniziò con questa avverte
vediamo scelto perché riuscì a chi per
la 32 enne ha faticato
[Applauso]
l'unicorno metri possono ora andiamo ad
unirli tutti e tre di bronzo bello
grande che andiamo a mettere il nostro
primo slide coccole di unicorno questo
qua e blu
devo ammettere la nostra mozione per
rumori di un ciclo line troppo cicli
slime preferiti
mettiamo baci di unicorno berlino è
molto interessata slime prossimo e sogni
di unicorno così vediamo anche come si
stanno che tre colori assieme
ecco qua il mio unicorn magic point live
finora lo store auguro sempre brembo yen
infine ora sono in vantaggio capita ora
vitale è arrivato il turno di rituale
numero
no non vedo l'ora una delle cantine
allora io stavo pensando siccome sono
team derbi team verde è meglio non
andare con il verde qui devo da forcella
ma attenti a non distruggere tutte e tre
le altre scatole perché so che colpirà è
molto forte con quel quanto ne dici ti
stai attento che martino sta facendo il
tifo per te troppi berlino dobbiamo
forse questo giallo 20 è stata molto
colpita troppo piano allora vado dai
[Musica]
[Applauso]
questo qualcosa di brutto casting
diciamo che fino adesso non è che mi ha
portato tanto verde questo mi ha portato
tanta fortuna questo verde
vediamo un po abbiamo l'abbronzante
abbiamo un colorante live quindi verde
verso chi ha portato verde e poi lo
shampoo verde verdi ha portato il bird
maggior mercato nessuna che ci sono solo
tre ingredienti che non c'è né altri
[Musica]
quindi devo fare lo slime con questi
ingredienti voli vedremo chi vince non
mi sa che finora sono in vantaggio
ok andiamo a mettere prima un pochino di
colla
berlino sta controllando la superficie a
nando dall'alto dei suoi bassi marino
anche la lingua lunghissimo di tanto
metti pure i tuoi ingredienti brutti
allora cominciamo da bellona vero magari
esce uno slam super berto verdissimo del
colore del mio team ma che bello verde
che strano che non è ma che non è
capitata nella maledizione del verde
perché io l'ho mangiato verde e io oggi
una maglietta gialla oggi farò lo slime
super verde verde vertici ma bellissimo
verde verdissimo bellissimo ha
contattato per la gente siccome ho già
messo tre ingredienti no
è inutile mettere il quarto che marrone
non c'entra niente col guardavano ha
iniziato dal verde bisogna farlo ti devi
mettere tutto quello che trovi della
scatola quindi devi per forza mettere il
marrone ma magari all'interno non ci
trovano cosa verde un'altra cosa che non
è marrone verde perché magari
all'interno ma guardo molto bello che
dici che non ti piace il verde arida
guarda che bello non c'è bisogno di
verde
se anch'io voglio fare bene come il
verde sia forte da poterlo mantenere
queste ore spiega marra morlino sta
supervisionando verde sopravvissuto
oggetto dei fortunati perché ha nuovo a
me questa volta io devo scegliere tra la
scatola rosa e quella verde così non
l'avrebbe poi vitale non potrà assegnare
perché la scelgo io e poi rimarrà quella
lui quindi una scelta molto difficile
questo non so quale scegliere
viene l'idea faccio altera pacifica non
so se me la ricordo tutta la canzoncina
dai la canti tour che la sta invece di
me io mi fermo una volta che finisce la
canzoncina
così almeno non ora responsabilità di
scegliere la stata sbagliata la
maledizione del verde non mi chiama radi
ambarabaciccicoccò 3 merlini sull'uomo
che così euro la biga reale carta
tombole ribatte manca più nessuno sono i
due titoli speriamo bene
pronti quasi tutti ho avuto tutto anna
vedo qualcosa dietro tutti la mia
morgano fortunatamente anche perché io
stavo pensando di scegliere quella verde
ma è normale non l'ho scelta anche se
non so cosa sia d'esempio potrebbe anche
esserci qualcosa di positivo
valverde molta fortuna non toccarla ma
che ha portato fortuna un cartello pur
con fortuna a me sa numero attente
fortunatissimo perché ho altri due
sdraie mandiamo ieri al mio mega drive e
abbiamo base di unicorno
so che il mio preferito perché rosa e
che cura e poi abbiamo giocato come di
ogni giorno gigantesca rete che mai però
di parlare con i viola io
allora mi capita se ti capita a sembra
di immergere le mani nell'acqua scorri
la pagina
no mi assicuro di guardia così almeno
sono sicuro di romperlo questa volta dio
che paura potete rispondermi l'urbania
berlino siamo pronti per questa verde
maria 32
no non ci credo
aspetta che mi devo togliere i guanti
uno sfortunato non è che bene o male non
ho avuto tanta fortuna ma alla fine ha
visto l'ultimo pacco l'ultimo
ingrediente cambiamo questa crisi e
super letterata che bellissimo però non
ci stia bene col verde
noi ci abbiamo i glitter in i blu e poi
questo pigmento turchese bellissima
sarebbe deciso inalterato ma poi
mettiamo dei baby sitter blu in poi il
turchese
[Musica]
non mi metto tanto perché sennò esce una
cosa brutta brutta brutta è bello è
bello line di vitale
molto verde mi spiace ma non l'ho fatto
perché mi sono capitati storage isla ma
che fortunata dai pro guardate che bello
che ora proviamo ad attiva
vediamo come diventa questo bellissimo
stop ed eccolo guarda un pò giocano
quasi domani che bravo tesoro recessione
news live è mio
non si vede l'abbronzatura noi nel
frattempo sta distruggendo qualcosa
berlino che stai facendo ha rubato la
bottiglietta vuota
però mi piace rubare le bottiglie ma ora
vediamo unicorn magic boston polvere di
unicorn m ma che belle ste sfumatura e
stupendo guarda guarda hai visto bella
fine è come il tuo ma più piccolo è
quello di evitare ma siamo molto simili
vedi qui la versione in miniatura
sfumati nessuno durata quasi in gara
[Musica]
potete trovare lì di unicorno magic box
live in edicola una tesi nei commenti
qual è il vostro preferito tra i 4 e gli
unicorni magic portion of slime e votate
nel sondaggio su ho vinto io o se ha
vinto vitale lasciate un bel mi piace e
ora vi lasciamo a 4 cappellino su cui
cliccare per mettere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quello che preferite
ebbrezza